do you think that men who
are very focused and are strong-willed
in their endeavors do you personally
believe like it is good to have like one
main chick i guess you could say that
eventually
you can trust because she brings some
sort of feminine qualities that help aid
in that mission
or do you see that men oftentimes like
spinning plates or seeing multiple women
women helps them with like a level head
and stuff because from my experience
what i've noticed with a lot of
entrepreneurs that i've spoken with is
that most of them end up gravitating
towards either wives or significant ltrs
and what i've noticed is that guys who
are entrepreneurs typically like if they
build some sort of rotation or plates
things like that a lot of times it can
end up causing like confusion and or
distraction from their purpose what's
been your experience with the guys that
you've talked to
yeah that that really depends on the
individual where they live and what the
dating pool looks like right so
um i think you're right though you know
for the most part most most
entrepreneurs that i've met they tend to
lean into you know conventional
um gender
i don't say gender roles so
they lead into conventional type of
relationships marriage um you know one
girl in a long-term relationship
monogamous there's also this new trend
also with a lot of uh tech guys where
um you know they've read a book like um
chris ryan's uh sex at dawn and they're
like you know into ethical non-monogamy
and polyandry and polyandry and all sort
of stuff
um but they're not unplugged right
they're still you know for the most part
plugged in betas and in some cases it's
like two guys with one girl so it's not
it's not really you know like the ideal
sort of um structure that you'd think
that a strong masculine alpha dude would
you know put himself in
um there's also guys that i know like
i've got this um follow-up to my first
book that i'm working on right now um
i'm going to include a story of what i'm
going to categorize as an alpha god
where he's basically running a harem of
probably six or seven women at any given
time he's got kids with them uh doesn't
live with them and uh he's very
successful you know business owner so
um there's really different ways that
your life can be structured and it's
like well how do you want to live your
life right like what is it that you want
to do right and and it's like in the
north american scope unless you're
planning on raising children
um
i don't see any point to marriage and
even if you want to raise children i
mean you really don't need marriage to
raise children like unless it's
culturally enforced by family values on
both sides and blah blah blah and all
that sort of stuff but for the most part
um you know there's no real point in
living with a woman
unless you want to raise kids together
right
so there's a lot of guys out there that
don't want kids or have already had
their kids out of the way and they've
been through the divorce machine
and they'll get married a second time a
third time or they find themselves in
you know scenarios where again you know
they get divorced and they live with a
woman or they invite a single mom into
their lives and he's got two kids and
she's got four and they blend their
lives and have like a brady bunch sort
of thing going on yeah and that's
usually where a lot of the problems
start to um you know arise i mean like
the
divorce stats and second marriages are
just atrocious man it's like you know 70
or 75 on a second marriage it's like 80
or more in a third marriage and it's
like you know
why would you give up half your stuff
like two or three times and potentially
be on the hook to pay support for kids
that you didn't even father yeah and you
know deal with all the fallout of all of
that plus the disrespect and the
aggravation and the headaches and it's
like that's gonna take you right off
your purpose i mean if you want to grind
and build a business and have an easy
lucrative and fun life why would you
invite those complications into your
life right most guys just don't know you
know they don't see it because all they
see is
you know just grind just on the business
but they don't want to take the blinders
off and like see the larger scope of the
world to see that you know
guys like this are incredibly smart like
they unplugged from corporate lies yeah
and they're like okay i don't want to
serve that master i'm going to do this
instead but they have a hard time
unplugging from societal narratives and
other conventional
um you know societal conventions that
plug you into a female first primary
social order that make you serve and
bend the knee to
a woman you know inside
marriages and stuff like that yeah i i
actually have a theory of why oftentimes
you'll see successful men do that or why
oftentimes you'll see them go down that
conventional route that complicates
their life and they they refuse to
unplug so to speak
what my theory is is that a successful
man what i've noticed is like he's he's
building right and he has like end goals
like brick by brick kind of you know
what i'm saying so he has like this
thing at the top and he's basically my
theory is like as an entrepreneur as
anybody with ambition is like laying the
foundation in their life to create more
and more success i think that oftentimes
they look at their relationships with
women similarly where if they have like
you know a monogamous ltr or something
like that what i personally believe is
they look at it the same way so they
tell themselves like you know i
shouldn't have to unplug or i have i
shouldn't have to look at the world a
certain way because since i am on my
purpose therefore since i'm a builder or
since i'm building towards something i
think that they apply that same
structure where they look at their
relationships as something to build on
with one specific woman and then what
happens is since they idolize or
pedestalize that one woman for long
enough since that's been their mindset
of building and watching the fruits of
their labor come about
it's hard for them to accept that
it's a different set of rules and it's
also hard for them to accept that
today oftentimes the dating game doesn't
work that way
i don't know if that's the i don't know
if that theory is accurate or not but
that's what i've seen is the hard-nosed
entrepreneur the hard-nosed driver like
he does not want to
have something that doesn't have an end
goal in mind or it's hard for him to
just accept that this is how things are
you know what i mean yeah i would say
that's reasonably accurate and i would
distill it with the sound bite that i
often use um
i always say that guys like to
complicate their lives and justify why
so what you just said there really just
boils down to that is is you know i'm
gonna do
these things
you know and then this
this is what's gonna happen and then if
it doesn't work out or if it's not going
their way then it's like well this is
why sort of thing so complicate life
justify why i think that humans in
general do it men definitely do it a lot
yeah they
love doing it with relationships and the
choices they make in their lives of
women money success careers businesses
it happens everywhere i mean like once
you start to unplug and you see the code
in the matrix like you see it happening
a lot
you